Last couple of mornings, I've woken up with anxiety, which is odd to me, is there any
nutrient or something I may be missing? With anxiety, you think of glutamate is your
first thing you think of. At least that's the first thing I think of. So glutamates are
excitatory neurotransmitter. So when you excitatory neurotransmitter, glutamate due to your
brain or cause anxiety, they cause OCD issues. They wake you up in the morning, so you need
glutamates. They're not bad, but just excess amounts will wake you up and make you anxious.
So where would you get glutamates? Well, you get glutamates from foods. So if you ate like,
you know, you went out to eat got Chinese food, guaranteed you, it has glutamates in it.
Anything prepared foods probably has glutamates because glutamates stimulate your brain. So
they put glutamates in the food so that you go, wow, this is really good. This tastes fantastic.
And it doesn't really taste fantastic. It's just making your brain think it takes fantastic
since stimulating your brain through glutamate pathway. Second thing is you could have
from a nutrient standpoint, you think of adaptogens. So adaptogens are adaptogenic herbs that
can help just calm your body and calm the anxiety. And you're going to look from a spiritual standpoint,
do you are there spiritual forces that you're attacking you and you're going to pray against those
as well. So you can dose three categories. Glutamates come from food, prepared foods. I'm not
eating any of that. Glutamates also come from glutamine. So if you ate a lot of neat animal protein,
we'll break down to glutamates eventually, especially if you have gaging defects.
Now it didn't eat any protein. So I just act eight vegetables yesterday and you would eat
a protein and I woke up with this. I didn't eat any prepared meals. We'll look at make sure you don't
have spices that have glutamates, modusodium glutamate is the most common thing you'll see. Don't
didn't have any of that. Then you think of adaptogens possibly in the spiritual direction.